Asta and the black Bulls just appeared
on the main Battlefield and confronted
Lucius and his paladins in what will
definitely be the final battle in the
entire series Austin yuno fighting
together again Yami and knocked fighting
together against Paladin Morgan
everything is about to end with this
battle Asta is about to become the
ultimate wizard King but this is not
even what everyone is talking about
because we just received absolutely
shocking news about the Black Clover
manga after the huge controversy
surrounding the previous chapter we have
just been informed that this chapter
chapter
368 will be the last Black Clover
chapter in weekly Shonen Jump magazine
the magazine that the series has been
published in since the beginning
after this chapter the Black Clover
manga is moving to Shonen Jump Giga a
sister magazine of weekly Shonen jump
that only comes out once every three
months Yes you heard that right this
magazine only comes out four times per
year and this means that the next
chapter of Black Clover isn't coming out
until December
this is huge news and honestly it's hard
to take it all in at once some people
think that this is good news others
think that this is terrible for Black
Clover and the fandom is an absolute
shambles right now we need to talk about
the craziness of the latest chapter and
the tragic fate of the Black Clover
manga so let's get into it you guys know
how this works if you enjoy our Black
Clover content and you want us to keep
it coming leave a quick like right now
to help me out with that YouTube
algorithm and despite the current
situation of the Black Clover manga I'm
working on a big black Clover video that
will be coming out soon please do me a
big favor and subscribe right now and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss that Black Clover video while
you're waiting and waiting and waiting
for the next chapter I'll still keep you
covered with the content right here on
anime Opera finally this video will
contain spoilers for the latest chapter
of Black Clover so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now as I
mentioned at length in my previous Black
Clover video there was a huge
controversy surrounding that chapter
because a everyone who was severely
injured was just magically healed again
including gray and gauche and B Asta was
suddenly able to share his anti-magic
with all his black bull comrades
apparently allowing all of them to also
use anti-magic along with Asta I won't
get into all the details here because if
you want a detailed breakdown on how it
happened and whether it all makes sense
you can check out that previous video I
will link it in the description and in
the pinned comment suffice it to say
that the events of the previous chapter
caused a ton of controversy a lot of
people were disappointed by what
happened and they thought that it made
the story worse while a lot of other
people thought that those people who
were complaining were overdoing it and
that Tabata can still pull off an epic
finish to the story the latest chapter
jumps back to the main fight against
Lucius inside the Clover Kingdom capital
in the battle between Yami and Paladin
Morgan notices that Yami has become a
lot stronger than he had been back when
Morgan was still alive Morgan
congratulates Yami on this achievement
but he also says that he can't afford to
keep spending all his time fighting Yami
so he has to bring this battle to an end
Lucius needs Morgan to accomplish a lot
more than just keep Yami busy so Morgan
decides to activate his second magic
attribute the magic attribute that
Lucius gave him when he was resurrected
as a paladin that second magic type is
none other than dark magic and we now
actually get to see someone using both
light magic and dark magic at the same
time which is absolutely crazy in and of
itself Morgan produces like a light
magic blade in his right hand and a dark
magic blade in his left hand and he then
proceeds to attack Yami with both
brutally overwhelming him in a matter of
moments
Morrigan says sorry Yami but I became
the strongest magic Knight on my own
referring to their shared goal of
becoming the strongest magic Knights
together and man just the idea of one
Mage using both light and dark magic is
extremely cool and under normal
circumstances I would talk about this a
lot more but we really have to move on
because there is so much going on in
this chapter and there is so much to
talk about regarding the fate of Black
Clover itself we then see the ongoing
battle between Lucius and his clones and
yuno who is still keeping up his
Neverland spell while trying to fight
off attacks from multiple luciuses Marx
is stunned by the fact that yuno is
still able to continue fighting against
such overwhelming odds but as impressive
as yuno is he can't keep this up forever
Lucius has the advantage over him and if
yuno takes one major hit from Lucius
Neverland will unravel we can't forget
that right now yuno and self's Union
magic spell called Neverland or never
Neverland is the only thing preventing
Lucius from destroying the capital and
all the innocent people inside it this
spell is currently boosting the strength
of yuno's allies and lowering the
strength of his enemies while also
neutralizing time magic attacks if this
spell were to go down it would be all
over for the good guy guys but just as
Lucius prepares to destroy all the
Clover Kingdom magic Knights and put an
end to this world someone calls out that
the world is not ending yet
suddenly the Black Bull base appears
right next to Lucius and the rest of the
black Bulls stormed the battlefield and
they are still in their anti-magic forms
so they can presumably use anti-magic
knocked and ichika appear in front of
Yami in order to protect him from
further attacks by Paladin Morgan and
man this is really an interesting
reunion right here knocked is reuniting
with his long-deceased brother who has
been resurrected as a paladin ichika is
finally reuniting with her older brother
Yami and this is going to be just so
interesting to watch on top of the Epic
magical clash between light magic dark
magic and Shadow Magic we also have the
dramatic personal Dynamics between all
these characters this is going to be
absolutely epic assuming Tabata is
actually able to spend enough time
focusing on this reunion because there
is so much to do right now at the same
time Asta appears and joins yuno's
battle against the multiple luciuses
Asta smiles and asks you know if he was
about to lose to Lucius before he showed
up and yuno smiles back and says not a
chance the Rivalry between the two
legendary BFFs is still going strong but
unlike so many other rivalries in Shonen
which are often about tearing the other
guy down so you can come out on top the
Asta and Yuna rivalry is really just a
race to the top both of them are trying
to become the strongest but instead of
trying to stop the other guy from
getting to the top first they are
actively helping and supporting each
other which is refreshing to see as a
somewhat concerned Lucius looks down
upon them both Asta and yuno Proclaim
that they will defeat Lucius and become
the wizard King and that is how this
chapter comes to an end as far as the
chapter itself goes this was awesome I
love the fact that the final battle has
now been fully set up everyone who needs
to be there is now there there are a
bunch of Epic Battles happening at the
same time a bunch of interesting and
dramatic reunions are happening as well
we're finally about to see the full
power of Asta and the full power of yuno
as they fight together against the
strongest villain honestly this was
great this chapter absolutely left me
wanting more and I can't wait to see
what happens next but that's the thing I
am still trying to process the crazy
news about the Black Clover manga but as
much as it pains me to say it we are not
going to see what happens next until
December Black Clover has been removed
from weekly Shonen Jump magazine and it
will be moving to the quarterly Shonen
Jump Giga magazine I am not overly
familiar with Giga but from what I'm
hearing from other people we can expect
the individual chapters to be longer
like 50 or 60 Pages which is cool but it
still doesn't make up for that massive
three-month gap between chapters I mean
I could live with longer monthly
chapters when I was super into Attack on
Titan back when that manga was still
going on but once ever every three
months honestly that feels like forever
naturally this shocking news has led to
a ton of fans speculation about the
ultimate fate of Black Clover some are
saying that the manga will now be rushed
to end as soon as possible and that the
next chapter that comes out in December
will be the final chapter of the entire
manga this doesn't seem likely to me
because if Black Clover was really going
to end in just like one chapter then
they could have just done it in weakly
Shonen Jump one last time after all the
literal final chapter of a long-running
series is sure to drive more sales to
the magazine so I don't think jump would
have lost anything by just letting the
series finish there it seems more likely
that there are still going to be at
least like three or four longer chapters
of Black Clover before the series ends
which means that the ending might come
in about a year I wouldn't hold out too
much hope that the series will last
longer than that because we are now
definitely in the end game and to be
honest such an Abrupt change to a less
popular magazine isn't exactly a sign
that the series will continue for many
years to come there are those who are
praising this change because they
believe that they will allow Tabata to
make a better ending for the story at
his own pace and without the pressure of
having to churn out weekly chapters this
sentiment was echoed by Tabitha himself
in his own statement regarding the
change where he apologized for the
sudden surprise announcement but where
he also said that publishing the final
chapters in Giga is a more optimal
condition and that it better aligns with
his personal situation as a writer let's
hope that jump really will provide
Tabata with the optimal conditions to
finish the story and that they won't
Rush him or force him to make
compromises now of course there are
thousands of people dunking on black
horror right now and saying that the
series flopped and got canceled but I
wouldn't pay too much attention to that
stuff Black Clover has been running for
368 chapters and counting it sold almost
20 million manga volumes it had a
successful movie an anime that is
rumored to be returning so yeah you can
can't say Black Clover has been
unsuccessful it's been extremely
successful overall it is not one of the
most successful Series in the history of
Shonen jump and anyone making that claim
is just coping but Black Clover still
made a ton of money for shueisha and it
was way more successful than so many
other series out there waiting for three
months for the next chapter definitely
isn't ideal and there is a very real
danger that the series will lose some
popularity because a lot of casual fans
have short attention spans and they
might just move on from Black Clover in
three months hardcore fans will of
course stick around but we have to be
real there are casual fans out there who
just read Black Clover as a weekly
series and when they don't see it for
three months they won't bother to stick
around as Black Clover fans we can't
pretend that waiting three months
between chapters is ideal but we can try
to make the best of it and we can hope
that the new magazine and the lack of
weekly pressure will allow Tabata to
give us a satisfying conclusion to this
epic story what do you guys think about
this crazy news are you afraid for the
future of Black Clover or do you think
that Tabata can still stick The Landing
how many chapters do you think we're
going to get before black horror comes
to an end how will Tabata end it will
anyone actually die will Asta become the
wizard king or will it be you know let
me know down below don't miss my
previous Black Clover video where I
talked about the huge controversies from
the previous chapter Link in the
description and in the pinned comment oh
and even though the next Black horror
chapter won't be coming out for a while
I am currently working on a big black
hole video that you won't want to miss
subscribe right now and hit the
notification Bell so you will be
notified as soon as the video drops even
though the Black Clover chapters won't
be coming out as often anymore we still
got you covered for Black Clover content
here on the anime uproar Channel